hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip where i'm going to show you
how to get
that radical retro vhs look
that is so cool so popular and we're
going to do it without using third-party
plug-ins
so i'm going to show you here's our
original footage you can see it's very
well lit
it looks really nice it's very
professional clean
crisp like i said great lighting but
let's dirty this up and let's
make it look like dirty
vhs tapes so what we're going to do
we're going to start with our footage
we're going to go to effect
channel we're going to shift channels
and we're going to
take red from red we're going to say
green is full
off and blue is full off we're going to
duplicate that layer
we're going to turn red full off
we're going to make green green and
we're going to set this
mode to screen then we're going to
duplicate this layer one more time green
is now
full off and blue is blue
and we're back to our original image you
may be saying okay why did you do this
because we're creating chromatic
aberration to start
the look and to make it look really cool
at this point we're going to
we're going to offset the x position
here it's 960 we're going to offset it
by 10 pixels
we're going to make it 970. so there you
go
super dramatic
shifting of channels here right a little
too dramatic but you'll see what we're
going to do
once we start applying some of these
other effects okay so next i'm going to
do is we're going to create a new
adjustment layer
and we're going to call this warp
and to this we're going to apply just
that we're going to distort
wave warp and we're going to change our
wave warp it looks
quite weird change it to square we're
going to leave the wave height at 10
we're going to wait make the wave width
1000 so very big
we're going to make the direction 0 and
we're going to make the wave speed
a negative 0.1 so it's very slow
and we're going to pin all of the edges
so if i play through this
you're going to see what happens here if
i zoom out there's a wave
effect happening a distortion effect
like an old vhs wrinkled tape happening
here
but let's take this a step further let's
actually duplicate this wave warp
and let's take the wave height
down to 5 and let's take the
speed to negative 0.13 so it's just a
little bit quicker
and let's move the phase to a 90 degree
angle and we'll preview this and you're
going to see we've got
two lines happening here one crosses
over the other
it's pretty thick there and it goes
pretty small pretty cool stuff
happening here let's go a step further
new adjustment layer we're going to call
this
effects and we're going to start the
effects
with color correction curves
and we're just going to add three points
here one
two three and we're going to
boost the blacks here bring those up
it's all a matter of choice here
we're going to bring down these whites
and we're going to create
a curve just like this
bringing up the blacks bringing down the
whites pretty simple
next we're going to go to color
correction we're going to go to hue and
saturation and we're going to
bump the saturation down to about
negative 35.
so with these two effects applied that's
how it looks
here's without and with pretty cool
okay next we're going to go to effect
and we're going to add some
noise and grain we're going to add some
noise and
noise is really easy to add too much to
an image to make it look pretty bad
but we're at 15 which typically is too
high
i stick usually around five percent six
percent maybe seven percent but for this
we're going 15
okay so now let's add a transition
effect and that's transition and it's
called venetian blinds
and we're going to go transition
completion about 10 percent
and we'll make the direction 90 and the
width we'll take it down to 5.
so again that's with venetian blinds
that's without looking pretty good
effect
blur and sharpen fast box blur we're
going to repeat edge pixels and we're
going to set our blur radius
to three and there you go you can see
now with that noise it's creating a lot
of
um if that noise wasn't bumped up so
much you wouldn't see much going on
there but there's our noise
and we're add one more effect which is
blur and sharpen
sharpen and we're gonna bump this up to
about 275 back out
and let's play through this and see what
we got and there we go my friends
that is a dope looking radical
retro vhs look just using
a few layers and a few adjustment layers
on top of it and look what we got